welcome to the show and what what a show
we have for you today let's start with
projection and voting the level at which
the right is projecting their actions
onto the left has really come to a head
on the topic of this recent Florida
election and subsequent recount that is
going on it is now being reported that a
heavily Republican County in Florida has
allowed some residents wait for it
to vote by email which you might be
wondering about and yes indeed that is
against the law I'm gonna reset the
entire story for you so that we all sort
of have all of the same information on
which to base our analysis so let's go
back a couple of years for years now the
right has been saying we need voter ID
we need all sorts of other voter
suppression policies because of voter
fraud mostly perpetrated by the left
they said people are voting for others
people are voting twice dead people are
voting not really the live people are
going and saying they are people who
have actually died the reality is that
that's not a problem
okay there's been a huge meta-analysis
by the Brennan Center for Justice which
found that there were in something like
1.3 billion ballots cast around 30
individual instances of fraud over like
a 14 year period or something like that
I mean the numbers were just
infinitesimally small so we cut to last
week the Florida elections happen it's
very close in the Senate race it's very
close in the gubernatorial race and you
see on election night Republicans in the
lead of rick Scott in the Senate and Ron
DeSantis apparently winning on election
night we then find out that there are a
whole bunch of ballots which simply
haven't been counted many of them found
at a mail handling facility in a liberal
part of the state miami-dade County
irregularities in Broward County another
one of the three sort of big blue
counties of Florida that are responsible
for a lot of the Democratic votes in
these elections
we've got questionable valence that
voting machines disqualified that we
need to look at by hand to really get a
final tally Republicans immediately say
oh this is voter fraud by Democrats
they're sort of implying that Democrats
dropped off bags of ballots after the
election was over at a mail facility and
of course there's no evidence of foul
play or fraud and if Democrats had a
plan of swinging the election with the
bags of paper ballots they would have
number one gotten them in before
Election Day actually took place and
number two they probably wouldn't have
dropped them off in a liberal area since
that would attract exactly this type of
attention so if Democrats are trying to
steal the election with paper ballots
dropped off late in a blue area they are
really doing something very stupid by
way of or in the hopes of swinging the
election fraudulently so over the last
few days we've had Republicans doing
everything they can to oppose the
recounts Donald Trump claiming voter
fraud with no evidence Sean Hannity on
Fox News saying someone should go to
jail for this and we've now learned that
in a very Republican County in Florida
this is Bay County where in 2016 Donald
Trump had 71 percent of the vote in the
presidential election the election
supervisor in Bay County his name's Mark
Anderson he has admitted he's not even
denying that he has allowed people to
vote by email this is against the law
this is not allowed now you can argue we
should have voting by email in the
United States we should have electronic
voting or you could argue that we
shouldn't but what you can't argue is
that we don't so this is against the law
this is a form of fraudulent voting that
the election supervisor has admitted to
why did this happen they say that it's
because of the hurricane but it's just
not adding up because after the
hurricane on October 10th Rick Scott who
is not only the senator elect in Florida
he's also the governor he put out an
executive order saying
we're gonna extend early voting we're
going to add early voting locations but
no votes can be submitted by email or
fax like he specifically addressed that
issue and people were allowed by the
election supervisor to scan or take
pictures of their ballots and email them
in and the election supervisor is
defending it by saying we are simply
taking care of voters Pat what about
taking care of voters by making it
easier to vote what about taking care of
voters by expanding voting locations or
early voting not because of a hurricane
but just because it's the right thing to
do or not purging voter rolls no they
don't do any of that stuff but now they
want to help voters by allowing a
Republican County to vote by email which
is against the law yeah sounds to me
like voter fraud and I estimate that
anywhere from three to five million
people voted illegally my thought is
that we have to put together a voter
integrity Commission to really get down
to the bottom bottom of this because
Democrats should have won both of these
races it makes more sense here than it
did after the 2016 election that's for
sure because these are hundreds of
instances of what Donald Trump claimed
three to five million people did in 2016
without any actual evidence and just as
I mean while we're talking about Trump
Trump said he would prosecute all
election fraud voting by email is a form
of election fraud is it going to be
prosecuted
I guess Rick Scott was right there
actually was a voter fraud problem here
but not in miami-dade County not in
Broward County in heavily Republican Bay
County you cannot write this stuff one
of today's sponsors is Skillshare which
is an amazing online learning community
that offers thousands of high quality
classes on almost any topic first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare they've got
classes on everything from design video
editing photography business technology
cooking meditation even classes on
personal productivity I know you'll be
able to find something on Skillshare
that fascinates you
or even something that will help you in
your everyday life classes are taught by
real people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of Skillshare but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up